Excellent work if you got these correct. When I expand each of these, I would
have three 2s, three 2s, and three 2s, That would make nine 2s multiplied all
together, so 2 to the 9th. For the second problem, I have 8 to the 4th raised
the 3rd power, I multiply 8 to the 4th, 3 times then I can expand each 8 to the
4th, so I have four 8s times four 8s times four 8s, So that's a total of twelve
8s multiplied together, 8 to the 12th. We use the same reasoning on this third
one, we have 5 to the 3rd three times, which means we would have nine 5s
multiplied all together, 5 to the 9th. For the final problem, we have x squared
to the 4th, our powers still apply to the variable. Remember, variables are just
numbers, so it would work the same in this case, as it does in these three.
First I multiply x squared by itself four times, then I have x multiplied by
itself eight times, x to the 8th.